and responsible for securing pension benefits for multiple generations,
it is a hugely important issue, how to manage climate risk.
We recently analyzed our global portfolio,
how it's aligned with the Paris Agreement.
It was diagnosed,
our portfolio is on the path for more than three degrees.
Far away from the Paris Agreement goals.
Our portfolio is not only sizable
but also one of the most globally diversified portfolios.
So that means, the world is on that path.
I'm tired of hearing the same comment repeatedly
from our portfolio companies and, obviously, investment professionals:
"We are realistic."
Sorry, but being "realistic" is no longer an option.
We are fully aware of our responsibility as the world's largest asset owner
to inspire changes in the capital market.
We will be actively engaging with all actors in the capital market
to move the needle.
I look forward to participating in this crucial dialogue with you all.
Thank you.
(Applause)
CF: I'm sure all of you know that throughout the past 12 to 18 months,
what has really been new and powerful and exciting
is the amazing voices of so many young people,
millions of young people who are out there on the streets,
with anger, with outrage, with despair,
and also, asking us to do our thing.
And they have been inspired by Greta Thunberg
but by so many other fantastic young people
in almost every country of the world.
And today, we are delighted to have four young activists
come join us today.
(Applause)
(Cheers)
Alexandria Villaseñor: This Friday,
I'll have been on climate strike for 52 weeks.
That's an entire year.
During that time,
I found that many people don't know about climate change
or how serious the climate crisis is.
So I founded Earth Uprising International
to teach young people about climate change,
because when they know the science and the impacts,
they want to take action.
Being an activist means making change happen.
Jamie Margolin: I became a climate activist
because my life depends on it.
I'm applying to colleges right now,
trying to plan for my future.
There will be nothing to look forward to
if we don't take urgent action to stop the climate crisis now.
I started the youth climate justice movement called Zero Hour back in 2017,
because this is zero hour to act on climate change.
We have no more time.
It became clear to me
that our leaders were not going to take real action
unless the people stood up and demanded it,
so that's exactly what we did.
Natalie Sweet: I became a climate-justice activist
because if I don't fight for the rights of the people today,
and for the people in the future,
who will?
Xiye Bastida: I became a climate justice activist
when I realized that the climate crisis impacts marginalized communities the most,
including my town in Mexico.
I strike with Fridays for Future
every Friday,
because our movement is not about gaining momentum
but about igniting cultural change.
But the fact that thousands of students strike for climate
means that we are already implementing climate justice
into every aspect of our lives,
which is already redefining the world.
JM: Over the course of our lifetimes,
we've seen the Earth deteriorate at a rapid speed
and groups of people traumatized and displaced
by an ever-increasing number of natural disasters.
In 2030, I'll be 28 years old.
AV: I'll be 24 years old.
XB: I will be 27.
NS: I'll be 26.
We want to be able to hand the planet over to our children
and our children's children,
just like many of you have been able to do.
AV: So unless everyone --
governments, companies, schools, scientists and citizens --
make a united commitment to reversing the damage that we've caused,
it will be too late.
XB: We are not only asking you to take care of our future,
we are also asking you to take care of our past.
Indigenous people have been taking care of the Earth for thousands of years,
which is why indigenous philosophy is crucial
when implementing climate action.
JM: This climate crisis can feel like an impossible thing to fix.
But it's not.
And it can't be,
because failure is simply not an option.
Failure means losing everything we love
and everything that matters.
So many of us are already working to save the future of our world,
but it can't just be on the next generation to fix.
This is too much of a burden to just put on young people's shoulders.
It is time for you to go all hands on deck
and do everything within your power to save everything before it's too late.
Are you with us?
Audience: Yes.
(Applause and cheers)
(Applause)
CA: Thank you. Thank you, thank you.
And then, of course,
there's a crucial role to be played by the world's storytellers,
and those with influence on social media platforms.
Each of the following has expressed excitement
to be part of this project.
They've lent us their names and support.
We have some of them here today.
Thank you so much for being here.
And let's hear from one of them, actually.
Jimmy Kimmel: Hi, I'm Jimmy Kimmel,
and I was asked to explain why I'm passionate about climate change.
And the reason I'm passionate about climate change
is the same reason people who are drowning are passionate about lifeguards.
I care about this planet, because I live on it.
I don't want to move to Mars,
Mars seems terrible.
I want my kids and their kids to be able to live on Earth,
with air they can breathe and water they can drink.
That's why I care about climate change.
And also, I have a crush on Leonardo DiCaprio.
(Applause)
CF: So with all these people coming together,
we have an opportunity to explore a new space of possibility
for solutions based on working together,
challenging each other
and inspiring one another.
So in October next year,
we will be inviting more or less 1,000 people
from different constituencies to meet in Bergen, Norway
to align on specific answers to our five big questions.
CA: It will certainly be an epic event.
But even more significant than what happens in Norway
is what happens elsewhere in the world.
Because on the final day of that conference,
we're planning a major activation of our global TEDx community.
TEDx allows initiatives to organize local events,
and there are now 4,000 such events annually.
Here's what they look like.
They take place in more than 200 different countries,
generate more than a billion views annually on YouTube.
We're expecting to see events in hundreds of cities.
We'll be connecting our TEDx organizers
with city mayors committed to a clean future for their cities.
This is the key to this.
It's this connection between the powerful,
who usually own the conversation,
and millions of people around the world.
Because of the zeitgeist shift that's happened in the last year or two,
suddenly, ignition can happen here,
because there's enough critical groundswell.
If we can give people visibility of each other,
connection to each other,
let's dream a little here,
and give each other permission to dream.
CF: So our goal here is to build connections
with and among all of the other organizations that are working on climate.
For example,
the Solutions Project is a wonderful initiative
founded by Mark Ruffalo and Don Cheadle.
And let's hear from some of the leaders that they have supported.
CA: Welcome, you're live.
(Laughter)
(Video) Wahleah Johns: Hi, my name is Wahleah Johns,
I'm with Native Renewables,
and we are working to provide solar power for tribes
throughout the world.
We have over 15,000 Native American families
that don't have access to electricity,
and we are working to provide solar plus battery storage for these families
in the United States
that don't have access to electricity.
And they are located on my reservation,
the Navajo Nation.
Anna Lappé: Hi, everyone,
I am Anna Lappé with Real Food Media,
and we work to uplift the stories of farmers and ranchers
as a key solution to the climate crisis.
The global food system right now is a huge contributor to this crisis,
but it doesn't have to be.
Farmers and ranchers we really see
as on the front lines of being part of solving the crisis.
So we try to share the stories of the millions of farmers
from Andhra Pradesh, India to the highlands of Oaxaca
that are using regenerative agriculture to build healthy, carbon-rich soil,
grow good food
and foster the kind of resilient communities that we need.
Rahwa Ghirmatzion: Hello from PUSH Buffalo -- my name is Rahwa --
where every day, residents are visioning, planning and designing
an equitable, holistic and sacred neighborhood,
like where I'm phoning in from, School 77,
a renovated vacant school building
that has the first 100 percent affordable community solar array
in New York state
installed by local residents.
It's also serving 30 affordable senior apartments
and a mix of intergenerational spaces
that serves as a community hub,
where we're practicing new economy strategies
towards a livable planet.
CF: Thank you.
CA: Bravo.
(Applause)
CA: It's so great.
CF: So you see, this is about everyone.
It's about cities,
it's about grassroots organizations,
but it's also, of course, about business.
And so we're inviting all companies --
underlined "all" --
to join this initiative,
to engage with your employees on how you can best protect the planet
and your future, at the same time.
So early next year, we'll be sharing a toolkit
that can guide companies
toward moving quickly towards science-based targets,
which gets them then to net zero emissions
by 2050 at the latest.
CA: So think about this,
because as an individual,
many individuals feel powerless on this issue.
But if you were to team up with others in your company,
you might be amazed at how much power you actually have.
Almost all emissions come from a company somewhere on the planet.
And the thing is, many CEOs today
are actually eager to help solve the problem.
We just heard this morning from Anand Mahindra,
who heads India's biggest business group,
that he is personally committed on this issue
and wants to be part of this journey with us --
he's a supporter of Countdown.
CEOs will be able to move much faster
if there's a group of employees there to brainstorm with, to support them,
to keep that sort of sense of urgency on the topic.
Our website will help you connect with others in your company
and give you guidance on smart questions to ask,
initiatives to suggest,
because if companies can be persuaded to do the right thing,
suddenly, this problem seems to become solvable.
CF: So all of these efforts are building toward one fantastic day:
Saturday, October 10, 2020 --
that is, "10.10.2020." -- easy to remember --
when this fantastic gathering will take place around the world.
And we hope to have, by then,
thrilling news of the report of the very specific solutions
that nations, cities, companies, citizens
are actually already collaborating on by then.
It's a day when every citizen of the planet
is invited to participate.
Your one ticket of entrance is you are a citizen of the planet.
CA: Key to the success of the event is for this to happen at scale.
We want to make it easy for anyone and everyone
to find out about the initiative and to play an active part in it.
But how do you do that?
You know, the world's a noisy place.
I mean, the TED platform can help a bit, maybe,
but there's a much bigger content platform out there.
It's called YouTube.
And we're delighted to be working with them on this endeavor.
We'll be inviting many of their top creators
to be part of Countdown.
Collectively, they could reach an audience in the many millions.
In fact, let's meet one of them,
Dr. Joe Hanson of "Hot Mess,"
a new web series about the impact of climate change on all of us.
(Video) My name's Joe Hanson,
and I am a YouTube educator.
And you can count me in.
I work with tomorrow's scientists, inventors and leaders,
and they deserve to know the truth of what the science says,
so that they can help us invent a better future for everyone.
CA: Imagine that multiplied by many others --
it's very, very exciting, honestly.
CF: And of course, when it comes to spreading the word,
every one of you in this room can actually play your part.
So if you have any way of reaching anyone
who is concerned about building a better future --
and that should be every single one of us --
please, invite them to join Countdown.
CA: There's one more card up our sleeve.
We're excited to unveil a global media campaign.
This is a campaign with a difference.
Just as TEDx exploded
by being allowed to grow as a grassroots phenomenon,
this campaign is designed to be co-opted everywhere on the planet.
If you happen to own a billboard company,
or a TV station, or a radio station,
or a website,
or a social media account,
we invite all of you to take the images you're about to see
and to just spread them far and wide.
Our website will make this easy.
We actually plan to translate them into many languages,
courtesy of our volunteer army of more than 20,000 translators worldwide.
Some of them are with us here.
If you're a TED translator, would you wave, please?
CF: There we go.
(Applause)
CA: Your work carries powerful ideas to every corner of the earth.
We're so proud of you, so grateful to you.
So this campaign's designed to grab attention
and to communicate, yes, urgency
but also a little smidgen of hope.
We think it might be that combination is what is needed to really drive action.
We'd love you to let us know what you think of these.
CF: Right now.
[Choose your future.]
(Applause)
[Turn fear into action Join the countdown.]
[Action inspires action
Join the countdown. The Earth will thank you.]
(Applause)
[10.10.2020 Climate's Day of Destiny. You're invited.]
CF: Remember the date.
[Mass destruction. No biggie. (If we prevent it.)]
(Applause)
[Giant asteroid heading our way The common enemy that can unite us.]
[We love natural disasters anyway -- said no one ever.
So why are we causing them?]
(Applause)
[Relax, there's nothing you can do about the climate
Unless you work for a company. Or live in a city.
Or own a phone. Or a brain.]
[Cause of death: Apathy. But there's an antidote.]
(Applause)
[Stop f*cking everything up
Inaction on climate is obscene. We can fix this.]
CA: Too much?
CF: No, not too much, yay, go for it.
(Applause)
[Have you gotten any action lately?
Here's your chance. Help turn the tide on climate.]
(Laughter)
CA: I didn't like this one, but my team, you know --
CF: Apparently, there are many who do like it.
(Laughter)
[We give up. Sincerely, TED.
Spreading ideas isn't enough. It's time to act. Join us?]
CA: This is, unfortunately, truer than you know.
[Some things matter more than partisan politics
Come fight the enemy that can unite us.]
(Applause)
[Stop burnout
Your company can help save the earth.]
[Give the planet more than you take from it
Join the countdown.]
[Despair, meet hope
We can avoid climate catastrophe if we take urgent action now.]
CA: That's it.
(Applause and cheers)
CF: To bring this full circle,
we would like to bring someone very special in.
(Video) Hi, I'm Claire O'Neill.
I am the COP president-designate for next year's Conference of the Parties,
the annual UN climate change talks, which will be in the UK,
and we're looking forward to welcoming you there.
But right now, I'm in Spain, in Madrid,
at COP25, this annual event
where we send negotiators and activists from all over the world
to see what we can do to reduce CO2 emissions.
But the problem is this: emissions are going up, not down.
And what I'm feeling is that 2020 is the year of action,
the year where we have to stop talking
and we have to start acting.
And not just here, in these conference centers,
but everybody.
And so the value of the TED process,
the value of what we're all doing together
is that we're spreading out the conversations
and the solutions from inside this space
out to everybody.
And I'm really looking forward to working with the TED group
over the next year.
2020, for me, will be the most important year for climate action,
and we're all going to deliver this together.
(Applause)
CF: OK, friends, so we're nearly there
but just a few more very special snippets.
First, a word from one of the many great minds
who will be accompanying us on this journey.
A message from the great author, historian and futurist
Yuval Harari.
Yuval Harari: Climate change is about inequality.
Inequality between the rich, who are mainly responsible for it,
and the poor, who will suffer the most.
Inequality between us, Homo sapiens,
who control this planet,
and the other animals, who are our helpless victims.
Inequality between the scientists,
who painstakingly search for the truth,
and the professional deceivers,
who spread falsehoods at the click of a button.
Climate change is about making a choice.
What kind of planet do we want to inhabit,
and what kind of humans do we want to be?
A choice between greed and compassion,
between carelessness and responsibility,
between closing our eyes to the truth
and opening our hearts to the world.
Climate change is a crisis,
but for humans, a crisis is always also an opportunity.
If we make the right choices in the coming years,
we cannot only save the ecosystem,
but we can also create a more just world
and make ourselves better people.
(Applause)
CF: So isn't that a powerful framing of what we have ahead of us,
and honestly, I think it is tragic
that the power of transformation that we have ahead of us
is so severely diminished by those who would want to politicize the issue
and separate it into partisan politics.
It cannot be a partisan issue,
it cannot be a politicized issue.
Happily, there are some who are working against that.
Today, we have one of those people,
a fantastically courageous climate scientist,
who is a committed Christian,
and who has been working on this issue
with conservatives and with the religious and spiritual communities for years,
with incredible courage.
Katharine Hayhoe.
(Applause)
Katherine Hayhoe: When someone says climate change, we often think,
"Oh, that's just an environmental issue.
People who are tree huggers or scientists care about it,
or maybe people who are on the left hand-side of the political spectrum."
But the reality is, whether we know it or not,
we already care about climate change, no matter who we are.
Why?
Because climate change affects everything we already care about today.
It affects our health,
it affects the food we eat,
the water we drink, the air that we breathe.
Climate change affects the economy and national security.
I care about a changing climate because it is, as the military calls it,
a threat multiplier.
It takes issues like poverty and hunger,
disease, lack of access to clean water,
even political instability,
and exacerbates or amplifies them.
That's why, to care about a changing climate,
we don't have to be a certain type of person.
A thermometer isn't blue or red,
liberal or conservative --
it gives us the same number no matter how we vote.
And we are all affected by the impacts of a changing climate.
So to care about a changing climate,
all we have to be is one thing:
a human, living on planet Earth.
And we're all that.
(Applause)
CF: And finally,
the man who brought this issue so powerfully to everyone's attention
years ago
and has continued tirelessly to work on that issue ever since.
The one and very only, Al Gore.
(Applause)
(Video) Al Gore: Thank you.
Thank you so much, Christiana,
and thank you for your outstanding leadership,
and thank you, Chris Anderson and the entire TED community,
YouTube and all of the others who are joining
in this fantastic initiative.
I have just three messages.
Number one, this crisis is incredibly urgent.
Just yesterday, the scientists gave us the report
that emissions are still going up.
Every single day,
we're putting 150 million tons of man-made global warming pollution
into the thin shell of atmosphere surrounding our planet.
The accumulated amount now traps as much extra energy every day
as would be released by 500,000 first-generation atomic bombs
exploding every single day.
And the consequences are increasingly clear --
all that mother nature is telling us,
the fires, and the sea-level rise,
and the floods, and the mud slides,
and the loss of living species.
But the second message that I have is the hope is very real.
We actually do have the solutions available to us.
It is unfortunately true at this moment,
that the crisis is getting worse faster than we are mobilizing these solutions.
But renewable energy and electric vehicles
and batteries and regenerative agriculture,
circular manufacturing,
and all of these other solutions are gaining momentum.
The late economist Rudi Dornbusch,
in articulating what's known as Dornbusch's law, said,
"Things take longer to happen than you think they will.
But then, they happen much faster than you thought they could."
We can pick up the pace.
We are gaining momentum
and soon, we will be gaining on the crisis.
But it is essential that everyone join --
of every political persuasion,
every ideological persuasion,
every nationality,
every division has to be obliterated, so that we, humanity,
can join together.
And in closing, I would just say that for anyone who doubts
that we as human beings
have the ability to rise to this occasion,
when everything is on the line,
just remember that political will is itself a renewable resource.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
CA: Thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Al, for your leadership on this issue
for so many years.
None of this would be possible
without an extraordinary and fast-growing list of partners.
I'd like to acknowledge them.
(Applause)
If you're watching this,
you believe your organization should be part of this,
you can help in some way,
join us, email me, chris@ted.com.
This is going to take everyone.
OK, before the Q and A,
I just want to ask you a question personally, Christiana.
Like, what do you really think?
(Laughter)
No, you've been in so many of these.
Does this initiative have a chance?
CF: Well, first of all,
we are at the point where everything plays.
Everything plays.
And I'm really excited about this,
because it has been very painful to me to see how over the past 12 to 18 months
because of the tragically insufficient response
that we have had to climate change,
how that zeitgeist has been changing from where we were in Paris,
which was pretty positive and optimistic,
to, now, despair, helplessness, anger.
That's what is out there, roaming on the streets.
And I don't blame them, and I have the same feelings.
But the point is,
we have to be able to transform that into making the difference.
And I think this is what this initiative is actually potentially ready to do,
which is to give every single person who feels helpless --
give them a tool to do something.
Some will contribute small efforts,
some will contribute large efforts --
depends on what your influence area is.
And to those who feel angry and despairing,
well, give them also an opportunity to channel that energy --
which is very powerful energy --
into solutions.
And finally, what is very exciting about this
is the scale, Chris, right?
I mean, just look at those partners that are going to be there.
We have attempted many, many things to bring to scale.
But this, I think, is the most promising initiative that I have seen,
to be able to bring people to scale,
to bring efforts and solutions to scale.
And speed.
Because if there's one thing that we cannot, cannot fail on,
is addressing climate change,
but not only that,
to do so in a timely way.
CA: Thank you, that is eloquent.
And thank you.
That's it.
(Applause)
OK, we have many members of the world's leading media here.
We're going to have a Q and A,
they should probably have priority on questions.
If it all goes deathly silent, someone else can ask a question.
If you're a member of the media here,
please feel free to put your hand up -- we'll throw a mic to you,
and we'll do the best we can.
Rachel Crane: Hi, Rachel Crane from CNN.
My question for you is about more specific action
that will come out of Countdown.
We heard a lot today
about how this is mobilizing the globe on this issue,
breaking people out of their silos, companies out of their silos,
but I'm curious to know, paint a picture for us,
of what the action that will come out of this initiative
could potentially look like.
I'm sure it's all in early phases,
we won't hold you specifically to this.
CA: There's an intense process going on between now and October,
where we're trying to engage
all of the world's best thinking on climate
around those five big areas.
What we're hoping to have there is multiple proposals in there
that collectively take a huge bite out of those issues.
Some of them, there may be one big one that dominates.
You know, so transport, for example.
Could we accelerate the end
of the internal combustion engine, somehow?
What would that take?
That would be a classic problem made for this approach,
because what governments decide right now
depends on what they see happening elsewhere.
Would the decisions of auto executives be shifted
if they saw millions of people on social media saying,
"I will never buy a combustion engine"?
Would they be shifted by the market signal of a few hundred mayors, saying,
"We are creating a carbon-zero zone in our city,
and we're going to expand it,
and we're doing that soon"?
Would they be shifted by a visionary auto CEO taking the risk
and coming forward and saying,
"You know when we said we were going to continue this till 2050?
No. We can see the writing on the wall,
we want to be on the right side of history,
we're doing this in 2030."
We think there might be a pathway to that.
So on some of these issues,
it's going to depend on a massive amount of discussion, bringing people together,
showing -- this is what you're so masterful at --
is showing that other people don't have the attitudes
that you think they have.
They're actually shifting, you better shift.
And so it's mutually raising everyone's ambition level.
And that is a cycle that happens,
and we've already seen it happening.
And so, on each of these issues, that's what we're looking for.
The biggest, boldest things.
Dream bigger than we normally do,
because there are more people at the table than there normally are,
i.e. millions of citizens engaged in this.
That's the process, and while that is happening,
there'll be multiple other engagements in companies and cities around the world.
We hope that it all comes together in a thrilling manner in October
and we have something to celebrate.
Dominique Drakeford: My name is Dominique Drakeford
with MelaninASS, or social media as a form of media.
In understanding the inherent correlation
between the accumulation of carbon in the atmosphere
and the cumulative exploitation
and extraction, extractivism economy,
which creates sacrifice zones for black and indigenous communities,
how do we plan to,
or how do you guys plan to mitigate those systems of oppression
as part of your strategies within those five various components,
so that we can really begin to reduce emissions?
CF: If the transformation in our economy and our society
does not include inequality closing and social justice issues,
then we're doing nothing.
Because all of those things will come back to bite us.
So we have to put our arms around the entire package.
That is not easy, but it is entirely possible.
And that's one of the things that I am so excited about climate change,
because it is at the front of this transformation,
but it will bring many of the other issues
that have been relegated to nonattention.
It will bring those issues to the fore as well.
So the transformation has to be an integrative transformation.
Ellen Maloney: Hi, Chris, hi, Christina.
My question is, are individual efforts,
like ditching plastic straws or going vegan,
making a difference
or are they just tokenistic drops in the ocean?
CF: Good question.
CA: It's a good question.
CF: They are totally important.
Absolutely important.
Because it's not just about the one straw that I use.
It's about me not using that straw,
going to a restaurant and telling the waitress,
"Excuse me, I don't want a plastic straw, because --"
and giving her a little lesson,
then she goes up to the manager, the manager comes to the table and says,
"Excuse me, could you explain that to me?"
Then you go through the lesson.
And sooner than you think,
you have that restaurant, plus the other ones.
Actually, information is contagious.
And wanting to do the right thing is also contagious.
So don't look at it as just simply, you know, "What is a straw?
Am I using the straw or am I not using plastic bags,
I have my plant-based bags to go shopping," etc., etc.
All of that counts.
It counts for you, first of all,
because it is a personal reminder of who you are and what you stand for,
but it is also a very important tool
to educate everyone around you.
CA: Right, and I think the core of our initiative is,
all that stuff matters -- what you eat,
how you transport yourself, etc., it matters a lot.
But there is another piece of power that individuals have
that they don't think about as much, perhaps,
and that we think that they should, we invite them to,
which is what they can do as an employee
and what they can do as a member of a city.
There's a coming together here,
where by getting organized, by connecting with others,
we think there is a direct route to changing decisions
that will have an even bigger impact on the problem.
So it's yes, all of that, but more as well.
(Laughter)
CF: There is an online [question], from a classroom of children.
CA: From a classroom of children?
CF: "What can students do?"
Yay, I love that question, totally love that question.
So first of all,
Fridays, 11 o'clock, go strike.
I mean, honestly, right?
(Applause)
Let's go, let's go.
And that pressure has to be maintained.
I'm totally delighted that there's some people here
who've been here doing it for 52 weeks.
The problem with this is, folks,
this is not a sprint, it's a marathon.
So you better get ready for many more 52 weeks, right?
And get more people involved,
because this is not easy.
If it were easy, we would have done it.
This is going to be a long-term effort.
But fantastic to be out there in the streets,
you are getting so much more attention from the media,
from us stupid adults who have not done our job --
it is fantastic.
So, you know, get your voices out there.
Also, in school,
you can definitely go and improve --
The question that you just asked to TED,
that's the question every student should be asking their school:
"Where's my energy coming from?"
Let's get with it, right?
Students in colleges --
how is it possible that we still have colleges and universities
that are not 100 percent clean energy
and that haven't shifted their capital and their endowment
over to low carbon?
I mean, it's just incredible.
(Applause)
And finally, the most important thing that young people can do
is ask your parents,
"What the hell are you doing about my future?"
Because here is an amazing thing.
I have spoken in -- I was thinking how many --
I've spoken to at least three if not four CEOs from the oil and gas industry.
I've spoken to three or four major investors,
heads of their investment firms,
who come up to me, usually in private,
and say, "Christiana, the reason why I'm changing what I do in my business
is because my daughter, or my son,
asks me at night, 'What the hell are you doing about my future?' "
That is a very powerful question,
and only young people can ask that question.
Use that tool --
ask your parents what are they doing about your future.
Sorry about the h-word.
(Applause)
Jo Confino: Hi, I'm Jo Confino, the HuffPost.
Christiana, a question for you,
which is one of the things that didn't come out so much
and this is about the spiritual traditions
and the role they play,
because what we're seeing
is that, actually, old wisdom is coming out
in terms of interdependence
and nothing is separate from anything else.
What is the spiritual tradition we can bring to this
that will make, also, a difference?
CF: What I think is very powerful about understanding,
whether you happen to be a spiritual person
that pursues meditation and mindfulness
or whether you're a religious person or not,
what I think is very powerful
about the spiritual understanding of the human presence on this earth,
is to understand that we are not separate.
It's not like, "Over there is planet Earth,
and then humans are over here."
And we are totally interconnected with all other species
and with all other living beings,
and doing the responsible thing by them,
does the responsible thing by us.
And vice versa.
And so that interconnectedness
is one that comes from the spiritual traditions,
but you don't have to be religious or spiritual to understand that.
You know, the fact is,
every single drop of water that we drink comes from nature.
Every single morsel of food that we eat
comes from nature.
And we've got to heal that connection.
CA: We would welcome engagement.
(Applause)
Kaley Roshitsh: Hi, Kaley Roshitsh from Women's Wear Daily.
Obviously, the fashion industry is responsible for a lot
of the carbon output,
so I wondered what is your perspective on conscious consumption?
CA: The key goal here is to align, at the same time,
to change opinion on what companies do,
what employees do, what consumers do.
It's the shifts all happening at the same time that can make change.
Right now, someone else is always the problem.
"Our investors wouldn't allow us to do that."
"There is no market for this better, more sustainable product."
And so, all the pieces need to happen at the same time.
That's our hope.
And so the lead on this is not us,
it's employees and CEOs and leadership teams
working in that industry.
Get together, make something happen.
And ride the tide of the zeitgeist shift that is happening --
it's going to work out from the business point of view as well.
CF: Can I jump on that as well?
Because for years, for centuries,
we have been on a consumer extract-and-consume mentality.
They way we go about our life
and the way that businesses are created
is extract, use, discard, extract, use, discard.
That's a simplification, but honestly, it's about as simple as that.
And to understand that that linear extraction to discard
can no longer be the case, that it needs to be circular now,
we have to go into a circular economy
that uses every single resource that we extract --
because we will continue to extract --
that uses it not once but two, three, four, five, 10 times,
around and around in circles.
That's a circular economy.
And we have to get to that point,
because frankly, we're running out of resources to continue to extract.
Jodi Xu Klein: Hi, my name is Jodi Xu Klein.
I'm with the South China Morning Post, a Hong Kong publication here in the US.
So, we've been reporting on trade war for more than a year,
and we're actually living in a world
where countries are decoupling from each other.
How do you overcome that trend and bring everyone together?
CA: We don't know,
these are really challenging issues.
What we do know is that we have to bring everyone to the table
and have the discussion.
There are so many people in China,
including, on many occasions,
the Chinese government has made bold steps
to tackle this issue.
There's a lot that the West can learn from what's happening in China.
CF: I would say,
in a world in which we're seeing a wave of nationalism and populism,
the way we go at this is actually to expand
the breadth of engagement,
so not to let the responsibility of engaging on climate
be in national government hands only.
Yes, they have an important role,
but we can bring it down as well
to a different level of engagement which is every single human being.
And once we understand that we're all human beings
and that we all have a common future,
there's no such thing as all of us being in a boat
and only the one closest to the hole in the boat are going to sink.
No.
Either we all sink or we all float together.
Justine Calma: My name is Justine Calma, I'm with The Verge,
thanks so much for this.
My question is about TED and YouTube's own carbon footprint.
Streaming video eats up a huge amount of energy,
and I'm curious what TED and YouTube
might be doing to reduce their own greenhouse gas emissions
connected to that.
CA: I can't speak for YouTube, obviously.
I will say that, to quote a line from George Monbiot,
all of us are hypocrites in this movement.
If you've ever bought something
or you're wearing clothes, or you're eating food,
you're a hypocrite, you're creating emissions.
It's part of life.
And I think perfection is --
There's a risk that perfection,
that an overpursuit and focus on that
and the judging that comes with it can slow everyone down.
We want this to be a coalition of the willing who accept
that they're not perfect but are willing to act.
Now, this whole process has sparked a huge conversation in TED
about how we act more responsibly,
and that will continue.
We're certainly not going to stop streaming videos.
At some point you have to do math,
it's like that -- give to the planet more than you take from it,
I think is the golden rule that I personally really believe in.
And so if an idea, powered by a little bit of electricity,
can ignite in someone's brain,
I would bet on the idea over saving the electricity.
But there's no perfection in this.
And we definitely have a lot that we need to improve on.
Let's go here and then back.
Lane Florsheim: Hi, I'm Lane Florsheim from the Wall Street Journal Magazine
and Chris, I really liked what you were saying
about the fashion industry and what they can do to change
and how it requires employees and CEOs to meet together
because who understands an industry better than the people in it
and their processes and infrastructure,
but I'm wondering, what about companies with huge footprints,
and two that come to mind first are Amazon and Zara,
where, by all accounts,
the workers, the employees there don't have very much power
and the CEOs don't have very much incentive to change right now.
What would you say about those kinds of companies?
CA: So this is going to be such an important conversation going forward,
because we're in the ironic position
where the people who can do the most to solve this problem
are the people who are currently the worst offenders.
So what do we do?
Do we make them part of the conversation or not?
I say we make them part of the conversation,
so long as we see serious engagement.
So take Amazon.
Jeff Bezos has actually listened to what many of his employees have said --
they've been very vigorous, the employee base there,
about carbon footprint --
has listened, has engaged with you and with others.
And they have announced, I think it's correct to say announced --
CF: Yes, they have.
CA: ... an acceleration of their own commitment
to go to, basically, a net zero track by 2040, if I have it right.
It's the companies with the thousands, the tens of thousands of trucks
and the packaging and all the rest of it.
That is how this problem will get solved.
So I say we invite these CEOs to be part of this,
and urge them to take it seriously
and to go fast and maybe even faster than they're completely comfortable doing.
But that's, I think, what we have to do.
Not to defame, denounce,
before we've at least had a serious conversation about,
"It's time,
your employees want to do this,
your customers want to do this,
your investors increasingly want to do this, let's do this."
That's our hope.
CF: And the wonderful thing about companies the size of Amazon,
or Walmart when they did it,
is that they have a huge trickle-up effect.
Because when Jeff Bezos came out and said,
"I'm going to make Amazon climate-neutral by 2040 -- "
Paris Agreement says 2050,
of course he wants to do everything better than that,
so 2040 is for Amazon.
Well good, we're going to keep him to it.
Now, the amazing thing about that
is that in order for Amazon to be climate-neutral by 2040,
they have to work with all their supply chain going up.
They have to work with all of those companies
that deliver services and goods to them
for them to also be climate neutral ASAP.
Because otherwise, they can't meet their own commitment.
So large companies are actually very, very key and instrumental to this,
because it's not just about their footprint,
it's about the embedded footprint that they inherit in their supply chain.
And the transformation of that is really huge.
CA: Last question.
Jackie Padilla: My name is Jackie with NowThis News,
and every day, I work with young climate activists
like the ones we've heard today,
but when we do stories on them,
you know, including Greta Thunberg,
I see fierce criticism that they face
and largely, it's because of a generational gap.
I don't know if you're familiar with the phrase "OK Boomer,"
but it seems like there's a lot of guilt or accountability
that some are looking for,
and on the other end, we're looking at a lack of education
or just ignorance on the issue.
So what is your advice to young people to respond to that criticism
to foster constructive conversations?
CF: We should probably ask them.
XB: Hi, thank you for your question.
CA: Come here.
(Applause)
XB: It is true that we increasingly face criticism,
and it's not only when we speak to people, with climate deniers
or things like that,
but also on social media.
It is as much a tool to spread information
and organize our strikes
and get the information out there,
but it's also a tool for people who want to undermine us,
to personally attack us.
And the way in which we stay resilient
is when we build community with each other,
when we organize,
we mimic the world we want to see.
There is no hierarchy in our organizing,
we are all working towards the same goal constructively,
choosing our passions towards making the strike the best it can be.
We got 300,000 people striking in New York,
we put together a whole concert,
people called it "Climchella," it was great.
(Laughter)
But the point is that it's not going to stop us.
The criticism is not going to stop us.
And even though we know that we are kids,
and we are not here to tell you all the solutions
that already are out there.
We are going to do it,
because every kid who cares about the climate crisis
is going to grow up to study through an environmental lens
and to change the world through that.
So we are here to tell you,
personally, climate activists that I know don't use "OK Boomer,"
because we strive for intergenerational cooperation.
And I think that blaming and dividing each other
is not going to get us anywhere,
which is why we don't use it,
and I don't think it should be used,
and I actually want to thank everybody who is doing something,
because action inspires action.
And you inspire us,
and we're glad that we inspire you as well.
(Cheers and applause)
(Applause)
CA: Wow.
CF: There you have it.
(Applause and cheers)
(Applause)
CA: There is no better note on which to end this.
Thank you.
(Applause)